the holidays are approaching and by
holidays i mean national nacho day it's
this saturday and not your daddy is
pulling out all the stops for a nacho
lover celebration and joining me now is
the culinary director for nacho daddy
daniel ray welcome thank you thank you
good to be back here my heart making
nachos for us today what what do we have
going on here for national nacho day
well it's a runner-up for uh christmas
and thanksgiving for sure 100 one of our
favorite holidays but
every day is national nacho day at nacho
daddy but uh we're gonna celebrate it a
little different than we normally do uh
we have two offerings for national
international day which is november 6th
we have the north of the border option
which is our burger nacho barbecue
chicken nacho and one of our
most popular is the buffalo chicken
nacho now basically these are like nacho
flights where you get a little taste of
everything you got three different
varieties here i love that yeah so you
have a nacho flight a beer flight
or one of our uh voted most popular in
vegas margaritas
and if you're living on the edge don't
forget our scorpion shot he has a real
scorpion and a shot of tequila
there is a breeze do you really eat that
yes you shoot it down oh my goodness
okay well let's make nachos i'd rather
do that okay sure what kind are we going
to make today to show us here so we're
just going to put together uh like i
said one of the popular ones which is
the buffalo nacho so if you want to go
ahead and take some of this white queso
okay and just pour it all over all that
yummy gooey goodness
white gold that we call that really what
kind of cheese is this this is a
house-made white queso uh-huh and all of
our ingredients are made in-house we are
fresh made from scratch kitchen
um so
we got the
right we don't open cans we don't do
that kind of stuff
we make it all from scratch
so i'm going to do a little bit of the
dirty work here and i'm going to take
these
buffalo chicken
put that over the top what a great
concept
one of our favorite snacks buffalo wings
put them on nachos to make the best okay
well we take some ideas and we twist
them and turn them and turn them into
nachos that's why we have the best
nachos in the universe 18 to 20
different types of nachos for you to
choose from vegetarian as well so we
have vegetarian vegan options if uh
that's what you're looking for do i need
to add some celery here add the celery
just sprinkle it right on top a little
crunch a little crunch a little uh
lightness to it make them healthy make
them healthy well
yeah give me they give you that
and then the green onions on top it's a
green onion
we don't need to be kissing anyone after
this well yeah we do actually on
national nacho day you got to have a
nacho and kiss somebody all right yep
and that's that's our buffalo
this finished product that's our
finished product okay i i'm going to
have to taste test them tell us about
some of the other varieties that you
have here okay so our south of the
border option that's available
on national nacho day is our south of
the border so we have a north of the
border and the south of the border
option
so the south of the border is also three
different style of nachos which is our
fiesta our supreme and our enchilada
nacho an enchilada nacho you can get
either red sauce or green sauce that's
fantastic plenty of food for you to eat
share with your friends your family just
have a great time
and how many locations in las vegas we
have three nacho daddies in las vegas
at planet hollywood shops
miracle mile shops
we have one fourth in fremont summerlin
and coming soon to henderson on saint
rose nacho daddy saint rose look forward
to that at the beginning of the year we
cannot wait these are fantastic thank
you